okay Susan Rice do you have confidence
that all votes will be counted fairly in
the 2020 election but here's what I have
confidence I don't I first of all the
key thing is whether people get to vote
and whether their opportunity once they
have voted is respected so we don't want
another weak reprise of what happened in
Georgia for example but if the issue is
whether interference from foreigners can
manipulate the vote tally that's a lot
harder than some people might think yeah
and that's because our electoral systems
in the states are distinct from one
another they're not hooked up to the
Internet and they've actually been
reinforced so in terms of foreign
interference I have some degree of
confidence in terms of what state
election authorities might do to try to
disenfranchise certain segments of the
population that I have more concern
about what do you think what is
everybody thinking about the bet I was
making with him well is it worth it yeah
cuz he would take my everywhere yeah I
mean I'd happily give my last penny but
I mean I've been you know I've been
saying for a very long time now that I
don't think he's leaving he did I mean
he wasn't gonna leave the first time it
was all about it's rigged he could lose
by a landslide in 2020 and I still think
he would say it's rigged fake news deep
State I just don't think you're gonna
get him out of there but bill if he left
office what would you talk about in your
monologue
I don't know what did I talk about the
23 years I was on TV before he came
along mr. sciences
[Laughter]
[Applause]
neil degrasse tyson what do you think
about mike Mulvaney proclaiming that
they will not discuss climate change at
the g7 summit yeah i well climate change
should be discussed at any possible
opportunity you are gathering people in
power to deny what is an objectively
true fact about what scientists have
recovered in the world is to delay what
might otherwise be sensibly argued
political decisions about how to address
the problem right but as long as you
keep suppressing it that is a recipe for
the end of civilization as we know it
ok part of a few g7 summit I know the
host country sets the agenda but the
other countries get a say and what I
expect is gonna happen is Donald Trump
may not want to have a formal session on
climate change but it will be on the
agenda because the other countries are
insisting the irony here is that I mean
but the rally is in Miami and it's gonna
be underwater in like 50 years cause of
climate change and they're just not
going to discuss it if you milk an
article maybe see I don't think it's 50
in the limiting case where all of
Antarctica and Greenland melt and that
sea levels will rise to the level of the
Statue of Liberty's left elbow right
that's up that's the end of London
[Music]
I guess I get chills when you do your
charlton heston
okay sir thomas Chatterton williams by
the way I heard um I heard out navvies
fantastic can you explain why you
believe Americans must unlearn race in
order to transcend racism sure because
research a lot about what your book is
racism creates race not the other way
around so I think that you have to be
able to do two things you have to fight
the racism that exists in the society
that we have and you have to also keep
an eye on imagining a better society
that we want to have I don't think you
can get a better future that you can't
first imagine so I don't think it's
enough to be anti-racist I think that
you also have to be anti race if this is
not a biological reality which which I
wanted to know I mean I don't think Neil
would agree that it's a biological
reality right it's what I what I can
tell you that when I'm asked what race I
am I say I'm the human race and when you
recognize any two people in the world
actually have a common ancestor not very
far back right in the tree of life that
to sit here and tribal eyes by whatever
possible little difference we can find
our monarch cells rather than seeing
what we actually have in common is an
abomination of civilization
[Applause]
to the fact that we are really still a
very young species yes we are at the
infancy really it's embarrassing it's
embarrassing what the hell is going on
right I also think in a hundred years
doctors will look at what we are doing
today the way we look at the way they
treated George Washington and Henry the
eighth they'll be like really you put
wood in his mouth you know he had an
infection did he and you put dirt in it
that was there are things we're doing
right now they'll be like anyway okay
Sam Stein what do you think of Shepard
Smith leaving Fox News well look
everything happens for a reason
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know I love [ __ ]
Shep is great and probably one of the
most talented if not the most talented
current live news broadcasters in the
business and his departure from Fox News
I don't know I mean we can all speculate
with backstories I think it's pretty
obvious but it's just a real loss for
the industry I mean it is important if
not vital to have voices like that on
Fox News I think it's critical and the
absence of that voice I think is going
to cause some real damage to our news
ecosystem and I'm I'm sad about it
honestly Danielle is Hillary Clinton
right and suggesting that Russia is
grooming Tulsi Gabbard to be a third
party candidate I couldn't believe she
said that what she said well she said
Hillary Clinton said that she was in the
woods so Hillary Clinton said not
touching that either Hillary Clinton
said that Tulsi Gabbard is one of the
Democratic candidates for president is
is is the best candidate for for Russia
and is the candidate that the first
accused Tulsi Gabbard of that well it
she's a Russian asset of some kind she's
the first very prominent person yes
you're right and then said that and then
said that that if that she wasn't sure
that the Russians would like go of Jill
Stein Jill Stein and give Tulsi Gabbard
that crown it was a I don't know what
the rest of you thought I thought it was
a very strange no it was inappropriate
honestly
what is she basing it on I mean
obviously there's anecdotal stuff that
she can point to but there's no actor
unless she has some information that
she's not divulging I don't think it's
really fair to know I mean but did you
see Tulsi gabbard's I saw her she said
it's a race that the Democratic primary
is now a race between her or Hillary
yeah and she did nothing to disavow her
embrace of I mean she should have said
I'm not a Russian agent I mean seriously
Tulsi gabbard's comments and actions or
question all she gathered is on
functionable as far as I'm concerned are
you kidding she went and propagandized
from Bashar al-assad
yeah she's unconscionable your guy's a
traitor he sides with countries meetings
with Putin and no one's allowed in the
room he does yeah but I'm not here to
defend Donald Trump defending Tulsi
Gabbard no I'm not really sure no I'm
attacking her like celery so I guess
that's what we have in common I thought
it was worth Nana prep looks like we're
all coming together
[Applause]
you